this video is sponsored by the great
courses plus
it can perhaps be a little stark but
equally profound and humbling to at
least once in a while
consider that the distance between us
and the mites on a leaf is likely far
closer than the distance between us and
understanding the universe as it
actually is
of course we aren't clueless we have
come exceptionally far relatively
speaking unlike any other living thing
we are not only aware that there is a
universe that surrounds and inhabits us
but we are also able to create models
and equations out of it that have
allowed us to extract understanding and
fundamental laws of nature from the very
surface of nature itself however despite
our profound abilities and achievements
we still have some of the most basic
essential questions left unresolved on
the table of everything unknowns that
permeate into the quintessence of our
existence and our experience of our
existence that no one has been able to
figure out since the start of it all
[Music]
at a young age we are taught how to tell
time and off we go flying through it
trying to keep up with it and use it as
best we can
for the most part time exists fairly
casually in the background of our lives
however to paraphrase the early
theologian philosopher st. Augustine
when someone asks what time it is we
know but when someone asks what time is
no one has any idea starting from the
Big Bang everything moved outwardly
through time and space in an
increasingly complex and disorderly
manner by way of the second law of
thermodynamics we know that everything
moves towards entropy from order to
disorder this creates what is known as
the arrow of time which as far as we
know only moves forward unlike in the
dimension of space in which you can
drive somewhere realize you forgot
something at home and then turn around
to go back and get it you obviously
can't turn around and go backwards in
time what you forget in the past stays
there in the 17th century Isaac Newton
proposed that time not only moves
forward but also moves at an absolute
fixed rate throughout all of the
universe this makes perfect sense as it
is how we intuitively experience and
understand time your minute is just as
long and just as short as everyone
else's
however a couple hundred years later in
the early 20th century Albert Einstein
provided his theory of special
relativity which disproved Newton by
revealing that time is far more
malleable according to Einstein's theory
time is in fact not constant or real in
the way that we are intuitively
accustomed to rather it is personal
relative and partly perceptual as in
everybody has their own experience of
time and the rate at which time passes
can change depending on what someone is
doing and where someone is this however
would only become noticeable in extreme
instances like if someone were near a
black hole or we're approaching the
speed of light where in both cases time
would significantly slow down
although profound and revolutionary to
our understanding of time this still
doesn't answer what time really is or
why we appear to only move forward in it
or why time is a dimension at all
leaving room for plenty of additional
theoretical models and arguments to be
made there are valid theories of the
universe that don't include time as a
dimension like the theory proposed by an
equation known as the wheeler DeWitt
equation other theories suggest that
time can be nonlinear and go back on
itself at the end of itself and a sort
of loop of displaced cause and effect or
congruent with Einstein's theories all
moments in time are occurring at the
same time just like all locations in
space are occurring at the same time and
the perception or sense that there is a
past present or future is merely an
illusion as a result of our continuous
forward direction through it of course
the point here is we don't know we
simply live with time experiencing every
moment through it coordinating every
activity on it and allowing it to
pressurizer every decision and
Sensibility and yet it could merely be
an illusion created by the brain's
feeble attempt to understand something
that extends beyond its limits to quote
Einstein we do not observe nature as it
actually exists but nature exposed to
our methods of perception in an
ironically similar string of events
Isaac Newton proposed what is known as
the law of universal gravitation in the
same work that argued for absolute time
in his theory Newton explained that
every particle attracts every other
particle with a force proportional to
the product of their masses and
inversely proportional to the square of
their distance between the center of
each particle in simpler terms objects
move towards each other in space because
of their force of gravity which is
dependent on the relationship of their
masses and distances between each other
some years later again Einstein proved
that Newton was wrong with this now
updated version of relativity known as
the theory of general relativity
Einstein discovered that gravity is not
the force between two objects but it is
actually the result of the mass of an
object distorting what is known as
space-time which is the combination of
the three dimensions of space and the
one dimension of time creating one
singular fabric of
universe as a result gravity works
somewhat and very loosely like putting a
bowling ball in the middle of a sheet
pulled tight on all ends the bowling
ball would cause the sheet to dip down
towards the center and Bend around it if
then a tennis ball was added on to the
sheet since the tennis ball has less
mass it would gravitate towards the
bowling ball but only because of the
distortion or bending of the sheet this
completely revolutionized our
understanding of gravitation and the
universe as a whole however it still
doesn't answer what gravity actually is
we can measure it and calculate it but
unlike other forces gravity has no
particle so we can't know what carries
it out we know that mass creates a
gravitational effect but no one knows
why mass creates a gravitational effect
it just does all the galaxies and solar
systems the earth in orbit us on earth
it all just seems to pull together with
no discernable explanation so far as we
can tell yet
[Music]
we know that everything that's anything
is made up of matter and energy being
interrelated aspects of the same thing
the first law of thermodynamics tells us
that energy can neither be created nor
destroyed however if this is true the
obvious question is what created it in
the first place
it appears that either something had to
have come from nothing or something has
always been in the case that something
has always been if time can in fact be
nonlinear and can infinitely regress in
a loop going backwards on itself at the
end of itself it would then be possible
that there is no beginning or end of the
universe at all but a continuation of
the same thing as if the universe were
breathing in and out filling up its
lungs with everything and then emptying
them back out over and over or similarly
everything is was and will always be
across space-time for all eternity
every moment in time and location in
space has a coordinate on the map of
space-time and the map exists at all
times
at the same time forever however in both
cases if something has always been
something where did that something come
from who or what made it how can
anything be anything without having been
made by something else
if the universe is entirely based on
cause-and-effect which it appears to be
how could there be no first cause for
there to be an effect alternatively in
what is known as quantum field theory
physicists have also found that
particles known as virtual particles
could come in and out of existence from
apparent nothingness which is to say it
is perhaps possible that a feature of
nothing is to create something however
if a feature of nothing is to create
something how can it be nothing and if
nothing isn't nothing what is it in what
made it even if one subscribes to the
notion of a god that's fine but that
doesn't resolve the question of where
God would have come from everything
ultimately brings us back to the same
question how can anything come from
nothing or something be infinite and
neither concepts seem to concur with any
human sensibilities meaning there is
some mystery of everything that our
brains can't seem to comprehend
as if the rules of the game were made of
logic but the reason for the game were
made of something else the only truth is
of course no matter what anyone says or
how they say it nobody really has any
idea what's going on beneath their feet
inside their brain and above their head
maybe at some point in the future we or
some iteration of us will know precisely
how everything works and why with one
little equation
maybe Newton will be wrong and Einstein
will be wrong and thousands of other
Einsteins of the future will be wrong
until someone somehow isn't and maybe
for some reason that's where we're
heading
however perhaps what matters is less
about what it is or why it is but that
it is that during this position of time
and space and in this form of matter we
can look into the nature of the nature
of everything and see that nothing is
simple and everything is insane and that
the only thing more insane will be to
waste it by never marveling at how
insane it truly is never appreciating
that we experience time whatever it is
in a way that allows us to experience it
at all that the effects of Earth's
gravity is just strong enough to keep us
on it but not so much that we can't move
around that the exact structure of
matter their exact forces form just
perfectly enough over billions of years
to allow us to emerge out of the
darkness for a little able to do this
right now able to enjoy the apparent
magic show of everything contorted
somehow just right for us
you
[Music]
this video was sponsored by the great
courses plus the great courses plus is a
subscription on-demand video learning
platform that offers lectures and
courses provided by leading professors
from Ivy League's
and top universities around the world as
well as courses by experts from places
like National Geographic the Smithsonian
and the Culinary Institute of America a
subscription to the great courses plus
provides you with unlimited access to a
library of over 11,000 video lectures
covering a variety of topics in subjects
like science philosophy history
literature and more as well as skill
based areas like cooking personal
development and arts one course that is
especially worth checking out is
entitled understanding the secrets of
human perception provided by Professor
Peter ambition with 24 lectures
professor vishton delves into the
various physiological and neurological
phenomena related to things like depth
perception color perception
self-awareness
pain emotion and perhaps most
interestingly how our sensory systems
can trick us into perceiving a reality
that isn't necessarily real you can get
your free trial of the great courses
plus today by visiting the great courses
plus comm slash pursuit of wonder or by
clicking the link in the description
below of course thanks so much for
watching in general and see you next
video
[Music]
you
[Music]